xbox it's had some excellent exclusives
these past few years and with all the
acquisitions microsoft's been
negotiating well that number is going to
be growing but in the meantime we put
together a list of 15 xbox exclusives to
sink your teeth into from indies to the
big hitters so let's get into it
microsoft flight simulator is an
absolute dazzling feat using real-world
data pulled from bing maps the game
generates a fully realized 3d earth
using a.i you can fly anywhere in the
world to your house to your friend's
house to my house it's absolutely absurd
and using what only can be described as
magic updates the in-game earth to
reflect changing weather patterns like
massive storms or hurricanes it's just
bonkers oh and it's playable on console
for the first time in the series
existence on the xbox series x and s so
that's pretty sweet
sea of thieves is great teaming up with
three friends to set sail delegate
responsibilities control the ship
treasure hunt navigate an expansive sea
take on an enormous shark or just drink
until you throw up on each other never
ceases to entertain me and have you seen
how good this water looks look at it
it's just fantastic it's a shared world
game allowing you not to only set sail
with friends but encounter other players
too whether you want to help them ignore
them steal from them or kill them well
that's entirely up to you the game is
filled with natural discovery and plenty
of scenarios that flip the script and
force you and your friends to react on a
whim also have i mentioned how good that
water looks and recently it added a
crossover expansion with pirates of the
caribbean to pack in hours of
story-driven content
okay okay yeah this isn't one game but
rather
six games we're talking halo combat
evolved halo 2 3 odst reach and halo 4.
but look there's no denying it halo is
king and few franchises have had the
impact on the medium that halo has and
the master chief collection is the
encapsulation of all of that whether
you're thinking of just dipping your
toes into the sci-fi melodrama or jump
into an online death match everything
you need is right here in this
collection
you don't have to know all that much
about cars that strap in and have a
blast with forza horizon 4. this entry
in the series stands out for the
introduction of seasons each of which
provides a unique experience to the same
tracks a course that's easy to drive in
the summer may be a whole lot trickier
when there's ice in the ground go figure
it's also just one pretty game to look
at car fan or not there's no denying
that
gears 5 expanded the scope of the series
more so than any entry before it
incorporating open areas that give you
the opportunity to tread off the beaten
path and pursue optional objectives a
welcoming change of pace in the
otherwise linear gears formula but don't
be fooled it still rewards the same
quick reflexes with satisfyingly brutal
depictions of carnage but throws in some
extra flavor to how you tackle
challenges depending on how you approach
an enemy base or the weapons you're
going in with this also picks up right
after gears 4 playing as kate diaz and
based on this ending that story isn't
over quite yet and this probably goes
without saying but it's multiplayer is
as top notch as ever
mist ah yes the cryptic puzzle game
classic this remake rebuilt the game
from the ground up with new art and
sound assets more interactions and even
an added option to randomize puzzles if
you're one of the veteran geniuses to
have actually finished this game like me
mist is absolutely great and this remake
makes an age-old classic from 1993
completely re-realized for the modern
age and if anything it's just worth
walking around exploring to hear its
soothing new age soundtrack
state of decay 2 has come a long way
since its launch expanding on a zombie
survival open world formula with
graphical overhauls new maps modes and
more story missions it's now a solid
game for those looking for that walking
dead experience where you're building
bases recruiting allies managing
resources maintaining relationships
scavenging for resources and creatively
fighting off hordes of the undead it's
also got co-op who said the zombie
apocalypse couldn't involve a little
teamwork
rare replay includes 30 games from the
studio's history from the era of the zx
spectrum to the 360. there is a hefty
heaping of titles from beat em up
battletoads and 3d platformer
banjo-kazooie to the first-person
shooter perfect dark and life simulator
viva pinata there's likely at least one
title included in rare replay that'll
tickle your fancy now unlike most games
on this list that are available on pc2
rare replay is actually one of the very
few to be completely exclusive to an
xbox console
adios is a game about a farmer but not
just any farmer it's about a farmer
who's got a job on the side disposing
dead bodies from the mob by feeding them
to his pigs that is until one day he
calls it quits and well this isn't the
sort of gig someone just gets up and
walks away from the end result is a
cinematic first person story that asks
the player to grapple with themes of
morality and grief but grounds them in a
relatable tale about two people trying
to come to terms with their lives it's a
nuanced drama that's sure to linger with
you and is absolutely worth your time
[Music]
the big con is a 90's animated tv fueled
adventure game oozing heaping loads of
nostalgia from that culture in the big
con you play as ally a teenager roped
into a partnership with a con artist
after finding out her mother owes 100
000
to loan sharks thrusted onto a cross
country trip ali is trying to scrounge
up any dime she can you'll be planning
your own cons and as a part of the
process strategically piece together how
to maximize the profits all of which is
held together with a solid story of a
young girl dealing with her mother's
expectations while handling her
blossoming queer feelings it's pretty
great and it's the debut title from
developer mighty yell
grounded is like if you took honey i
shrunk the kids and smashed it with
minecraft it's especially a fun setup if
you have friends to play it with you
build bases and weapons to protect you
from critters that will want to eat you
and in the process must uncover remnants
of a secret lab that may hold the key to
how you got shrunk in the first place oh
and if you don't do that well with
spiders don't worry it's got an
arachnophobia mode that makes them a
little less scary
ooblets is a bizarre but charming blend
of farming simulator and creature
collecting rpg so it's basically stardew
valley meets pokemon which is probably a
lot of people's dream game in this case
however instead of beating the creature
into submission and make it your own you
do a dance battle you play as the newest
resident of badge town where you're
given a worn down farm and the choice of
your starting ooblet as you fix up your
farm you'll be able to plant crops to
sell you can also journey across the
region and challenge other trainers in a
dance battle which kind of plays out
like a card based game as mentioned it's
bizarre but charming
in a lot of ways insomniac games as
sunset overdrive is an early precursor
to the developers follow-up marvel's
spider-man it's an open-world adventure
that makes you the superhero like
guardian of sunset city after an energy
drink turns most humans into mutant
monsters like marvel spider-man after it
sunset overdrive mixes combat and
movement and rewards you with bonuses
for shooting your arsenal of guns while
wall running griding across phone lines
or bouncing on top of cars it's fun
quite bombastic and at times pretty
hilarious
[Music]
the veil shadow of the crown is a
fascinating take on an action rpg
because
you're blind therefore all the usual
run-of-the-mill stuff you do in rpg like
fighting enemies sneaking around guards
firing a bow walking through the market
is all entirely done with sound you have
to listen to enemies shuffling around
you and exhaling as they swing a sword
to know where and when to parry and
attack or pick out the clinging of a
blacksmith's hammer and miss a busy
market to figure out where to go for new
armor it's totally unique and a
fascinating approach to an otherwise
cliche genre
[Music]
and there you have it the 15 definitive
games that all xbox one and series
console owners should consider checking
out thanks for watching and don't forget
to give us a thumbs if you found this
video helpful oh and if you're not
already consider subscribing too to stay
up to date for everything related to
gaming okay take care folks
[Music]
you